tu abuses toi te moquer des gens qui
marchaient des béquilles non monsieur
bah vous en ai moins revu ton malin
tenez la chambre la chambre l'agent
[Musique]
merci un nom de m'avoir poussé non non
c'est moi j'ai poussé jamais j'aurais
fait ça et si vous l'avez fait je vous
est ce que je vous ai pensé oui mais
poussé
j'ai senti votre souffle putride
derrière ma nuque fraîchement rasé alors
ne dites pas que vous m'avez pas pousser
je vais s'éparpiller un volet pas poussé
je vous ai pas pousser mais alors
comment j'ai fait alors je les ai pas
repensé donc je vous ai retenu vous avez
laissé tomber non c'est pas vrai ce sont
des chiens
non assistance à personne en danger si
on appelle ça vous savez que je pourrais
porter plainte
vraiment verriez vous ai raté la marche
on peut recommencer la marche vous
voilez ont leur comme ans descendait à
marie
qu'elle s'est même fait non j'ai pas le
temps jouer à
qui souffre est la boue est là non j'ai
pas envie de jouer et j'ai pas envie
ouais ouais pas mal poussé je vous ainsi
requis je vous ai pas pousser diola je
vous ai pas pensé non mais je vous dis
franchement si vraiment je possède je
vois pas pourquoi mais aussi pour me
faire tomber pour fou pour rigoler mais
non mais non
je ne sais pas possible c'est gonflé je
suis c'est moi qui fait gonfler j'étais
très marche derrière vous faut pas
pousser non mais n'importe quoi je sais
que vous vous êtes pleven méchant
[Musique]